الحقيقه الاعتراف
طائرات المسيره وان جاء متاخرا الى لم يكن
المفاجاه
في ردود فعلها الرسميه على مدار الايام
الماضيه على الاتهامات التي وجهت لعبد
تثبيت موسكو الطائرات المسيره لم تنفي لم
تنفي اطلاقا تثبيته بالنسبه للمعدات
التصريح الذي تبنته السلطات الايرانيه
وعدد كبير من المسؤولين السياسيين
والعسكريين في ايران على مدار الايام
الماضيه هو ان طهران لم تزود موسكو
حربيه بحدث استخدامها في
الحربرانيه اليوم تصريح امير عبد الله لا
يخرج كثيرا عن هذا النطاق هو قال ان طهران
لديها علاقات دفاعيه لديها اتفاقيات
دفاعيه دفاعيه مشتركه مع همم روسيا
وانها زودت روسيا بعدد محدود جدا من
الطائرات المسائيه وذلك قبل شهور من وقوع
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه همم واكد عبد
الله ايام ان ايران ليس لديها اي علم بان
روسيا استخدمت الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه
في الحرب على اوكرانيا همم قال ان ايران
او سلطات الايرانيه او وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه كانت قد اخبرت اوكرانيا بانه في
حال تثبيت ايران بادله ووثائق تثبت ان
روسيا استخدمت همم هذه الطائرات المسيره
في الحرب في حربها على اوكرانيا فان ايران
لن تقف مكتوب في الايدي دون ان يحدد ما هو
ما هي رده الفعل التي يمكن ان تتبناها
ايران في مواجهته حاليا روسيا ودعيمها في
مجلس الامن بطبيعه الحال هذا الامر حظ
يعني همم كان له انعكاسه واسع في الشارع
الايراني هناك طيف من الايرانيين حقيقه
يفتخر بهذا الانجاز يقول ان الطائرات
المسيره التي كان الغاز على انها طائرات
ورقيه وبالمجرد العوف فوتوشوب ليس اكثر
الان يدعون ان روسيا الدوله العظمى القويه
عسكريا تستورد هذه الاسلحه همم من ايران
هناك طيف اخر من علي الايرانيين على ضفه
رجعتقد ان روسيا اوقعت بايران مره اخرى في
مصيادتها وهذا الامر الذي قد يعرض ايران
لعقوبات دوليه جديد التي لا تفاقم الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه هنا في ايران يعتقدون ان روسيا
بشكل متعمد اخرجت هذه الاخبار الى
الوسائل الاعلام بهدف يعني احاكه مشكله
جديده بين ايران والغرب وامريكا توعيه
امكانيه التواصل الى الاتفاقا